neural networks work extremely well by
taking the same underlying idea and
applying it to different kinds of
training data we can have a deep neural
network do things as varied as playing
the game of go recognizing cancer
translate languages and even drive a car
it seems like there is something special
about the core principles of neural nets
that makes them uniquely suitable to
being applied in a wide range of
potential tasks and some people might
argue that this hints at the very early
ideas of building truly general
artificial systems now despite the
unreasonable effectiveness of these
neural nets we've seen a long Academical
journey to try and understand why these
networks are as effective as they are
and so in this video I want to dive into
all the Academical research that tries
to look at what we already understand
about the learning dynamics of deep
neural nets so specifically we'll take a
look at the remarkable ability of neural
nets to memorize huge amounts of
training data even if there is no
specific pattern present there well then
take a look at how the surprising result
changes our views on learning dynamics
of these networks and finally I'll
introduce a very interesting theory that
tries to explain the surprising result
from the viewpoint of information theory
if you want to learn more about the
learning dynamics of deep neural
networks then I hope you're ready to
dive in deep my name is Xander and
welcome back to archive insights
[Music]
deep neural networks often have far more
trainable parameters than the number of
training examples that they're trained
on and for some unknown reason they seem
to generalize very well despite
violating the conventional rules of
statistical learning now to understand
why this might be the case we'll start
with a very interesting line of research
from 2017 where a team of researchers
did a series of experiments to
investigate how good neural nets are at
simply memorizing their training data so
in the first experiment they trained a
deep confident on cipher 10 which is a
data set of 60,000 32 by 32 images
divided into 10 classes but next to the
normal training regime we're all used to
that in a whole series of interesting
experiments that hint at some very very
interesting characteristics about these
deep models so in one of their
experiments they replaced the target
labels so the output classes of those
images with completely random labels so
in this case there is no clear
relationship between the input images
and the target labels that the
classifier needs to learn to predict a
nonetheless they showed that when you
take a simple two layer neural network
and you train it for long enough it
actually manages to memorize the output
labels which are completely random of
all 60,000 images in the training data
achieving a training accuracy of 100%
and sure I mean we all know that neural
nets can over fit but that's pretty
impressive right
and they also executed variations of
this experiment where the labels are
kept unchanged but the images themselves
are replaced with totally random pixels
and sure enough the network again
manages to memorize the entire training
data set next they interpolated between
100% random labels and the actual labels
and then they compared how much time
different network architectures needed
to overfit on the data as well as how
that affects their generalization error
on the true test set in the data and in
the graph here you can see that for some
mysterious reason
a newer architecture like Inception for
example which has a lot more parameters
than say Alex net or a normal perceptron
somehow manages to get a much better
test accuracy on the true test set
when trained on partially corrupted
labels and that's kind of interesting
and then finally the researchers
investigated how far they could push
this memorization experiment so what
they did is they took the image net data
set consisting of 1 million two hundred
and eighty thousand images replaced all
their labels with random ones and sure
enough after training for long enough a
large model Inception v3 was actually
able to achieve a training accuracy of
over 95% on completely random labels and
obviously these networks that were
fitting random input-output
relationships well they also got random
performance on the test set which is to
be expected because they didn't learn
anything
the main point though was to show that
these networks are very very capable at
simply memorizing input-output
relationships even if there is no
explicit structure in that data set and
so all these experiments they basically
begged the question well if these neural
nets are so good at just memorizing the
training data well why do they
generalize at all why are we able to
train a network on a training data set
and then it actually manages to do
something useful on an unseen test set
because if the network were only doing
memorization then that wouldn't be
possible and now of course many people
will say sure but when we're training a
network we actually apply explicit
regularization we use things like drop
out l2 norm to basically penalize
memorizing the data set and that's the
reason that these networks generalize
but in fact we know that even without
those explicit regularization techniques
the usual neural nets still do pretty
well on unseen test set so
regularization alone doesn't explain why
these modern architectures generalize as
well as they do so then what is going on
well to dive deeper into this intriguing
story let's take a look at a line of
research that was actually an answer
from yoshua bengio
group on this initial line of work so
their assumption was that yes of course
these networks can learn to memorize the
training data eventually but in fact
these networks will tend to exploit
actual patterns in the data and only
later employ memorization to completely
over fit on the training data and so to
test this their main idea was that if
the network is learning simple patterns
first well then we should be able to
find some examples in the training data
that fit these simple patterns better
than others or in other words you know
some images in the training data should
be easier to classify than others when
we're early on in the training process
of our network however when we're
training the same network on random
noise of random labels then this
difference between easy and hard
examples should be much less clear
because everything is random anyway and
this is exactly what they found so when
they tested this on cipher 10 they saw a
large variety in the output probability
of the correct class label proving that
some real images really are easier to
classify than others when training on
random labels however there was no such
easily exploitable pattern you know
forcing the network to rely entirely on
memorization instead additionally they
also showed that for real data you can
actually get quite good performance with
a very small Network because those
simple patterns are kind of easy to
learn but if you want to memorize random
data and you actually need a much bigger
network to do that
and finally the paper contains a lot of
interesting experiments of how different
types of regularization actually affect
the fitting or convergence time of a
network when you train it on real versus
noisy data so it's actually really
interesting to take a look at that paper
the link is in the description so in
summary the work by bangerra's group
basically showed that the learning
process of neural Nets is content-aware
in the sense that the network will try
to exploit the easily accessible
patterns in the data first and only then
start going to memorization in order to
completely minimize its loss function
all right so the picture we have so far
is that these deep neural net
seem to be very capable at memorizing
large amounts of training data but when
we train them on actual real data they
have a tendency to first exploit actual
patterns and only then start overfitting
by memorizing the remaining noise in the
data and now to get an even better
understanding of this entire story I
want to dive into a related line of work
that emerged during roughly the same
time period by enough tally Tish P and
Henrik Schwartz from the Hebrew
University in Jerusalem so their main
idea was to look at this entire learning
process through the lens of information
theory and specifically their entire
analysis builds upon the idea of mutual
information so I want to spend just one
minute to really clarify this concept
before we move on
so mutual information is a statistical
quantity that measures how much one
random variable tells us about another
it is generally expressed in a number of
bits and you can think of it as the
reduction in uncertainty about one
variable when we have knowledge of
another so high mutual information
indicates a large reduction in
uncertainty whereas low mutual
information indicates a small reduction
and zero mutual information between two
variables simply means that the
variables are independent of each other
and that's really all we need to know
for now so in the case of neural nets
the random variables that we're going to
look at are the hidden activations
inside the layers of our deep neural net
more specifically we're going to look at
the mutual information that each layers
activations contain about the input
image X and the target label Y so when
training a deep neural net each layer is
basically getting information from the
layer below it and transforming that
information into a new space by using a
matrix multiply and a nonlinear
activation function and so in this sense
a deep neural net is just a large Markov
chain of these nonlinear transformations
that progressively transforms the data
space into the label space and the chain
is Markov because the computation is
blocked
or in other words each representation
can only be calculated once the previous
layer has finished its computation all
right so with those ideas in mind let's
dive into Tish B's work and trust me
it's some pretty beautiful stuff now the
first thing that we can notice about
these mutual informations is that they
form a chain of inequalities that are
called the information paths and this
basically tells us how much information
is there in the activations of layer 1
about the input and how much is there in
layer 2 about the input and so on and
because the network forms a Markov chain
of these transformations the mutual
information about the input can only
decrease as we follow the flow of data
through the network and in fact the same
inequality also holds for the true
desired output labels why since every
layer transformation must always lose
some amount of information and nowhere
can there be more information about the
output class than in the image itself
all right so now let's dive into one of
the most beautiful visualizations of
deep learning that I've ever seen and
now let Tish be himself explain what the
setup looks like so these two
coordinates the information about the
input versus the information about the
outputs of the desired output are going
to tell us a very interesting story so
in order to see this I I'm going to use
this movie that some of you may have
seen but it's always very important to
see it again
so what you see here are these two axis
that the x-axis is the information that
each of the layer has about the input
the y-axis is information that this
layer has about the output and the
colors represent layers of a specific
neural network which I trained hundred
times with different random initial
conditions and different training data
and so what we're currently looking at
is the initial condition of the network
where you can see that the first hidden
layer in blue contains quite a lot of
information about the input X and the
target labeled Y and this kind of makes
sense because most of the information in
the image is still present in that first
hidden layer even though it passed
through a single
you know computation on the other hand
for the output layer of the network
which is an orange has very low
information about both x and y which
also makes sense since most of that
information gets destroyed by all the
random layer transformations in the
network remember this is a picture of
the network before training so all the
weights are still random and now let's
take a look at what happens to this
picture if we start training the network
on the MS data set so the very first
thing that happens is that all the
layers rapidly move upwards which kind
of makes sense because this means that
they are learning to extract information
about the target labels why however at
the same time the layer activations also
move to the right meaning that they
learn to retain more information about
the inputs X or in other words they are
memorizing the input data to some extent
and teach B calls this the fading phase
of the network and then after this first
phase of fast fitting first phase of
fast filling yeah the network dynamics
transition to a second much slower
learning phase where the layer
activations actually continue going up
but now they move to the left in the
information plane or in other words
they're actually starting to discard
some information about those input
images and the general theory here is
that it's actually in this second phase
that the network learns to forget or to
ignore the irrelevant parts of the input
pattern so these are basically the
things that are not labeled in the
images like the background or different
lighting or brightness conditions you
know noise in the images all of those
things and THP calls this the forgetting
phase of the network
if you look at the number of epochs we
can see that the first phase happens
relatively fast after about 300 epochs
of doing stochastic gradient descent but
the second phase happens much much
slower converging only after about 10000
epochs and now you might wonder what
happens through this story if we start
training our network on subsets of the
training data well it turns out that our
story holds as long as the training data
set is sufficiently large in this case
we quickly converge the green line after
which the
very slow forgetting phase starts which
makes the network robust to the
irrelevant parts of the inputs but on
the other hand if we train with only 5%
of the data then we can see that if we
keep training beyond the initial fitting
phase the layers actually start moving
back down in the information plane so in
other words they are losing information
about the output labels of the test set
and so this is what traditionally has
been called overfitting
but Tish be himself prefers the term
over compression since what's basically
happening is that we're compressing the
representation of the data to a point
beyond what we're allowed to do in order
to generalize to the test set in this
entire story of what is happening during
training in the information plane is
actually beautifully backed up if we
look at the gradient signal that is
flowing through the network so this
beautiful graph right here shows the
average mean and standard deviation of
the gradients for each layer during
training of the network so in the
fitting phase the mean is quite high and
there is very little noise or in other
words there is a very stable learning
signal for the optimizer but then in the
forgetting phase the mean of the
gradient drops significantly while the
noise actually picks up or in other
words the signal-to-noise ratio of our
learning signal actually drops
significantly and this perfectly
explains why the second forgetting phase
is so much slower than in comparison
with the initial fitting phase and
finally I think it's also very
interesting to look at what happens
through this entire story if we start
playing with the depth of our neural
network so what you see here is the same
training process on exactly the same
training data but now visualized for
different depths of the neural network
and you can immediately see that the
shallow network containing only one
hidden layer in fact follows the exact
same dynamics as we've seen but the
compression or the forgetting phase just
takes a very long time to converge in
fact even after training for 10,000 a
pox the network still hasn't converged
so while a shallow Network can in theory
learn to
represent any function in practice it's
actually very hard to learn that
function in a reasonable amount of time
and in contrast adding more depth to the
network seems to dramatically speed up
the convergence time now obviously I
don't have enough time in a 20 minute
video to dive into all the beautiful
details but if you want to build up some
intuition on why adding depth to the
network actually you know makes this
training convergence faster I would
really recommend to check out the entire
talk by Tish be himself I will link to
it in the description it's beautiful so
this turns out to be quite interesting
because this gives us a completely new
understanding of why the layers help you
and I'm going to finish with this so to
wrap up here if we go back to the
essence of the problem it really comes
down to this surprising result that
neural Nets that often have millions of
parameters I mean much more than the our
training examples somehow managed to
converge to local optima that seem to
generalize very very well to unseen test
data and so in other words to explain
the successful generalization of neural
nets there must be some kind of magical
force that actually regularizes the
network during training and now as it
turns out many recent Academical
research actually points to the inherent
noisiness of the stochastic gradient
descent process as one of the core
components of this generalization
success and so this issue is a lot of
very interesting research questions like
Tish be himself says maybe we should be
using more random noise to make better
compression algorithms okay so we know I
mean what what what is it in in in these
stochastic dynamics it's actually put
you to optimal compression this is not
something we used to have in information
theory I mean nobody as far as I know is
composed are many random codes all over
the place but nobody is using noise I
mean random walks
I mean diffusion processes in order to
compress maybe you should and so as
always everything that I've just said is
the current view of what we know about
deep learning but obviously there are
many people with different ideas and
there's a lot of things that we simply
don't know yet so what I want to end
with is a couple of
interesting directions of problems that
we simply have no answer for just yet so
we know that sarcastic gradient descent
relies on randomly sampling mini batches
in order to inject noise
therefore converging to flat local
minima and then also generalizing to the
tested but the question then is how does
that relate to the learning in
biological systems where the input data
is simply a continuous stream of highly
correlated inputs I mean these two
paradigms seem to be completely opposed
to one another secondly it's often
quoted that the simplest program that
can explain your data is the best one
and we'll generalize optimally one fact
it's actually a fact it's a mathematical
theorem that you can prove is that if
you could find the shortest program it
does very very well on your data then
you will achieve the best generalization
possible with a little bit of
modification you can turn it into a
precise theorem and on a very intuitive
level it's easy to see what it should be
the case if you have some data and
you're able to find a shorter program
which generates this data then you've
essentially extracted all the all
conceivable regularity from this data
into your program and then you can use
these objects to make the best
predictions possible like if if you have
data which is so complex but there is no
way to express it as a shorter program
then it means that your data is totally
random there is no way to extract any
regularity from it whatsoever but then
how does that relate to this ongoing
trend in deep learning where the number
of trainable parameters in these models
is simply growing exponentially while
also getting better on the same tasks
along the way I mean those two things
seem to be opposed as well and then
finally what is the link of this entire
story when we look at unsupervised
representation learning where we don't
actually have any labels at all so
currently a lot of people are
investigating what the optimal loss
function in
that case should be for example right
now most people are using things like
reconstruction losses as a training
signal but it's quite clear that that is
really not the optimal thing we should
be doing so the real question is when we
as humans grow up and we learn to
understand the world without any
supervision
what is our brain really doing alright
so as you can see many interesting open
problems remain but at least we're
gaining some insight into the internal
learning dynamics of these wonderful
deep neural Nets thanks for watching
maybe think about liking or sharing this
video and I'd love to see you again in
the next episode
of archive insights I think we're done